[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the legendary
broadcaster he's jimmy brockmeyer good
friends with hank azaria
and we thought it would be fun to have
him on he did give us a
uh celebrity bracket but known as a
baseball guy
and uh jim brockmeyer joining us on the
program have you ever called a college
basketball game there jimmy
you know i did very early in my career i
called games
uh for the basketball program at the art
institute of kansas city
very very bad team uh filled with
performance artists and
interpretive dancers and mimes very
frustrating because they they could do
very impressive physical feats but they
had no clue how to play basketball it
was uh like watching a bizarro version
of the harlem globetrotters
but the mimes are very good at boxing
people out dan you see what i did there
with the boxing
you see that see see what you did there
jimmy i i
you set him up you knock him down yeah i
went old school with you on that one i
don't know why i always
want to imitate your voice when i'm
talking to you you you just
you have that unique delivery and i
always want to get into
jimmy brockmire maybe you know i was a
kid growing up listening to you and
maybe
i don't know maybe tried to emulate you
a little bit
it gets in there doesn't it like it's
like i'm like you're jiminy cricket i'm
like the voice of your conscience it's
like
embedded would you rather go out for
beers with vin scully or uh the late
harry carey
well what a wonderful question you know
i mean the obvious i've been with both
the obvious answer is harry kerry
i'm going to say ben scully because
here's the thing about
vin he does not go out for beers he goes
out for a beer
and at least this was true in the 80s
when i went out with him without telling
anybody
dan he dr he likes to drop acid and it
turns into a
crazy evening i mean if you think here
in vince scully called a baseball game
is perfection
just wait till you hear him narrate his
own mental journey into the fourth
dimension
remains one of my most treasured
memories as a baseball announcer is
watching a shirtless vin scully describe
the ayah god
in the chavez ravine parking lot while
trying to ride a coyote like a horse
which he did do
it's a good thing there wasn't social
media back then yeah
it would have been i never would have
filmed them well actually i probably
would have been
posted i mean it's a strong accusation
there what you just made
it's not an accusation it's uh it's a
celebration
um how many plaid jackets do you have
i have i have two this was the original
uh this was 18 and then they made
another one for me because
it got a little got a little seedy and
smelly yeah so i had to have another
go-to yeah
when people see you on the street what
do they say to you
uh you well they usually avoid eye
contact with me
several of them um several of them i've
had run-ins with often i never know who
i'm
so much of my life has been blacked out
that i never know i have people coming
up to me accusing me of stuff and i used
to take umbrage and i realized you're
probably right i probably didn't do that
so uh but uh you know they say hey
aren't you that guy and i say oh you
know i'm wanted in several states so you
probably have seen my picture at the
post office when did drinking on the air
start
i think it's as old as time isn't it i
mean uh
for me right from the beginning i mean
uh i was the youngest uh
youngest uh man the youngest person
never called a professional baseball
game i was 21 years old
and uh i started right in i learned from
the best i didn't know that you could
actually could call a game without him
is it so you can get is it makes
baseball tolerable if you've been
drinking
i mean who uh i guess joe buck just
recently
shared yes he did that he and troy like
to have a couple
um you know i look i don't know about
football but
baseball man you got to fill a lot of
time with a lot of words dan patrick i
mean it
does make it a lot easier i mean there's
a reason why fans enjoy beer at the game
it's no different from the announcers i
mean you got to get through that thing
somehow
are you okay with implementing uh
digital strikes on they're get they're
gonna do that in the minor leagues
but uh and then i guess see how that
works and bring it into the majors
yeah i've accepted i don't know if i'm
okay with it i've accepted it as
inevitable i have a tinge of
disappointment
about it because i do love the
uncertainty of the human empire
i mean there's nothing like being in a
stadium packed full of people
waiting anxiously to hear the opinion of
an out-of-shape middle-aged man
you know it's an experience you usually
only get it at baseball games at the
republican national convention
but i hope the hope the digital strike
zones do have some variability
you know uh keep a little of that human
umpire craziness like every every april
fool's day
i'd love it if there's a knob they can
turn that sets the machine to like angel
hernandez or something
i'm gonna miss seeing managers argue
with these guys
i think at the very least they should
allow teams to have a robot assistant
coach
one that's programmed to fight with the
umpire like a tiny little one with a
chicago
white sox hat on a little tony larumba
and he can roll out there and yell
afterward and
spray dust on home plate or something
he's the legendary jim brockmire the
minor league baseball play-by-play
voice best advice that you give to those
that would like to try to succeed in
this field what would it be
boy usually i discourage them both out
of sympathy for them
trying to save them and their parents a
lot of heartache but also jealousy
like i try to i try to cut the cut young
people off at the knees
dan because i don't want to deal with
them i know these millennials are
getting my face you know what i mean and
uh
so i don't offer too much encouragement
i try to i try to intimidate them and
discourage them where are you working
this uh spring or this summer i'm
currently uh uh between
i have a new pow that's a nice segue
have a new podcast coming out a jim
brockmeyer podcast wait so you're not
doing baseball
uh well no taking a little break between
jobs don't want to go into why i got
fired from the last one but
um so this is uh you're between jobs not
by your
doing it's never by my own doing dan no
you may have done it but you're in
between jobs because somebody's not
going to hire you
yeah or they just i'm currently i'm
between
jobs okay as what we like to say but
an opportunity for this podcast thing
okay uh
i had they had to have a young person
come to me and explain the difference
between the radio show and a podcast
and several hours later i still did not
understand but apparently i agreed to do
it
pretty sure i was blackout drunk for
that too do you know is there what's the
difference stand between the radio show
and a podcast is there any difference
no commercial breaks during a podcast oh
okay
see i just thought it was one of these
modern term things like they liked it
like it's not a snowstorm it's a polar
vortex
not a vegetable it's plant-based you
know it's not a radio show it's a
podcast
well podcast can go as long as you want
it to go radio
you know i it's like podcast is an extra
inning game
who knows how long it's going to go
thank you for putting into terms i can
understand yeah
yeah by the way uh the top of your head
looks nice uh
uh your your uh your cranial sprouts
we still call it hair do i have to say
cranial sprouts uh
you can call it hair i can't yeah yeah
did you are shoe still shoes they're not
foot impact reduction
no i think they're shoes okay great yeah
so podcast
yeah i don't want you to adapt to today
i want you to continue to be you from
yesterday
i agree but these kids today make it
harder and harder no no you be you
jim all right i'm going to take that
with me and to my next job but i'm lucky
enough to get hired i'm going to take
that advice with me
how's your love life by the way uh uh
disturbing
as usual um i uh in between
in between women quite literally like
you can't see it wait there are two
women in there
yeah on either side wow yeah it's like
those
tv shows from the 70s used to love that
that cliche from tv shows
guys would walk in with two babes on
their arms yeah
i never saw that in real life did you no
no
i i i didn't i'm still looking for it
but no i've not seen it like i dream a
genie is not
real no i'm pretty sure that was that
was not a documentary no
no it was not um so you're in the
bracket challenge
apparently you guys asked me to do it so
i did it yeah
and uh do you have any idea what you're
doing
well you know i tell you you asked me to
do it so i you know i tried to take it
seriously i spent about
i stared at this bracket for like 15
minutes uh mostly just trying to care
trying to work up some way to care about
it uh couldn't do that
uh failed at that but uh you know i
i under normal circumstances i find it
uh who cares but this year it's really
weird i think it's strange we've trapped
a bunch of college students in a hotel
for our amusement
sounds more like the premise of a
pornographic film but you know i did the
bracket
so my process was
i started by writing two of the final
four at oral roberts
oral roberts and morehead state i know
that's immature don't care
work backwards from that
in the midwest i have loyola chicago
getting knocked out in the first round
apologies to sister gene
and i wasn't allowed to write this in
the prediction but i believe that due to
a combination of covert 19 and the power
of sister jean's christian prayer
loyola chicago will rise again in the
third round like jesus
but then lose again immediately to
illinois
never grow up jimmy okay i will not
i will not and and i wish you well with
uh that podcast there
and um and and i hope to talk to you
soon
it's coming out in april charles barkley
is our first guest i hope you will join
us
and we're going to have luminaries from
the world of sports
is there alcohol involved of course then
i'll do it
just by showing up on my blood alcohol
level you could probably just breathe
near me and you'll get nice and wasted
jimmy brockmire uh jim thanks for
entering the bracket challenge and uh
we'll talk to you soon
thank you dan patrick always a pleasure
jimmy brockmire
not sure i believe all the stories that
he tells but he tells it in a unique way